pas une nuit pas un jour
sans ce bruit anxiogène des
bombardements et des sirènes
tel est le nouveau quotidien des
habitants de kiev une ville qui compte
désormais plus d'hommes en treillis que
de famille
défendre la capitale ukrainienne coûte
que coûte c'est la promesse que c'est
fait artiom javaux rankhof pourtant ce
grand gaillard n'est pas ukrainien mais
russe
c'est ma boîte de survie dans laquelle
il ya tous mes documents
je ne peux pas avoir de passeport
ukrainien y anime au bouc serez je ne
suis pas vraiment fier de celui ci
artiom n'est pas retourné en russie
depuis l'annexion de la crimée il y a
huit ans il s'est engagé en tant que
volontaire pour distribuer des plats
chauds plus anciens
et se dit prêt aujourd'hui à combattre
les soldats de son propre pays
il y a le camp de la justice et celui de
l'injustice moi je veux être du côté de
la justice tu me la mort pour lou si je
suis ukrainiens en russie
je ne sais pas faire comme si rien se
passer si 71% les reçus porte poutine
ils sont aussi responsables de cette
bière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa mère âgée de 70 ans vit toujours en
russie il lui envoie régulièrement des
vidéos des bombardements de son quartier
mais elle peine à croire ce que lui dit
son fils elle me répond que ce ne sont
pas des missiles russes les ukrainiens
c'est trop difficile pour quelqu'un qui
n'a connu que la propagande de changer
sa vision du monde de cette chaîne ne
veut pas voir pour ne pas se détruire
elle mais intérieurement
victoria yves leiva a elle aussi quitté
moscou pour kiev quelques jours après le
déclenchement de cette guerre qu'elle ne
supporte pas cette célèbre photographe
russe est la seule journaliste à avoir
pénétré à l'intérieur du réacteur
nucléaire accidentée de tchernobyl en
1991 ça c'est la partie de réacteurs et
là silence était complet je me sens
assez mag
parce que c'est c'est difficile de dire
que tu as appartiennent un pays fasciste
oui c'est moi c'est ce mot là oui j'ai
senti que je dois être avec ces pays pas
avec le mien parce qu'elle je soutiens
la vérité toute ma vie
là aussi coupable je suis sur une guerre
que victoria yves leva souhaite
affronter les yeux dans les yeux le
coeur écartelée entre son pays natal et
ses convictions les plus intimes